hey guys is dense the founder take care
of and I'm David Griffin resident comic
book in video game guru and this is a
review of agents of shield episode 10
the bridge this is the mid-season finale
finally and i have to say i I'm so I'm
disappointed I mean for show that's
that's already disappointing this
midseason Fallon finale was really a
disappointment because I was like ok
they're they're saving all this stuff
and maybe like they're gonna turn a
corner with his midseason finale and
leave us with this big cliffhanger that
that uh that we're all gonna like go be
like oh man they really set it up like
all these episodes no no none of that
not no that's not happening with this
show one thing with the episode I do
like the addition of the the guy from
the the pilot right he's in the premiere
of the guy from angel the major right
yeah i like it like Peterson my Peterson
they kind of you know got him in quick
and kind of dust all that stuff that
happened you know before out of the way
but I think it could be a good addition
to the team it didn't what didn't make a
good mid-season finale but it did at
least hopefully the team will be a
little stronger with him there I mean
I'm kind of mixed on him like I think in
the potential in the future that he
could be a good addition to the team but
for this episode and care no really care
about his character he was kind of just
like now he's like this reform kind of
kiss ass dude and it seemed like it
happened to cooks like wait didn't she
almost just killed one thing like wait
yeah just and I didn't like I love how
the new tomorrow which was just like
throw-in big names expected to like do
something like that's like oh did I beat
Captain America's record I'm like you
just can't throwing Captain America's
name with it doesn't make the episode
good or the show interesting I'm still
not again assist the characters i don't
know i do like the band i do like the
banter between cigna weighing now way
and what's his name take a right Rachael
Ray and grant grant and and made you
like to see when they were training in
the you know work well with team he's
like well think i have been working well
so i think i like it just gotta stared
him down like I will kill you mention
that I do love her well they she got
upset because he had like saved her
during battle right right so yes there
is a good dynamic there because it's
kind of
Greg feeling better but it's also kind
of an odd couple think you don't really
see them together but then you kind of
can see how it could work yeah they have
an odd relationship at least it's
interesting right I like the scene where
grant went up to the girl of the college
and gave her like his car and jail again
150 thousand dollars and and you know
he's like well maybe you can help me out
and she's like what's your hopes no I
mean that there's some funny moments but
i'm not sure if it makes the whole
episode no i mean every episode always
has some funny moments or funny banter
funny situations but as a whole I'm just
not invested into these characters into
care and in the in the story lines
aren't that interesting so far and i
thought i thought this episode would be
the one I below yeah they're going to
tie in all these other these previous
episodes yeah because we watched ups on
the beginning it has that whole montage
of like every thought everything that's
happening season but a lot of the stuff
with so I get organized your toy
soldiers at one woman with the growth of
flower dress and all that and nothing
really came out of he well she came back
you know with that guy Edison yeah broke
him out of prison yeah I keep talking
about this clairvoyant I mean I don't
know if they're gonna reveal is clever
only to be a major character in the
right in the marvel universe or
something he's like psychics don't exist
or something like that yeah but as of
right now I just don't I don't know I
don't feel anything for it well I mean
that's the thing it starts I and always
say this we repeat this over and over
again every great show and I've ever
reviewed or ever talked about always
starts with characters Battlestar
Galactica is good because it's not has
to do with the ships or the Cylons it's
the west wing in space basically it's a
great political drama it has some
theology in it we care what the
characters care about the subject matter
but you can't just put something the
Marvel Universe it's like oh it's Marvel
therefore it will be good morrow wasn't
a great job with their films awesome job
but this show is just it's suffering
yeah internet even like with a character
like Agent Coulson that we care about
him being taken at the end yeah you know
and they kind of like you know there I
don't know if it was in in the end of
the episode or in the teaser commercial
where they showed like flashes of like
his Tahiti you know vacation after his
death and like how
but it's not that interesting like I
think I think they thought it was gonna
be like duh like Coulson's back like
we're gonna you know be totally like
drawn into this mystery or Coulson and
we're not really yeah I mean yeah I hope
they can turn it around in the second
half maybe I have a feeling we might cuz
I don't know how far they've shot ahead
i don't know how where they are in their
shooting process I think we might not
see a change until the end of season one
and who knows that the ratings keep
falling or what they're where they're at
right now if we may not see a season two
I don't know it's possible i mean the
ratings definitely aren't that great and
maybe see might not let their baby goes
it is marble but their marble show fail
they'll probably give it another season
that's my guess like can we turn the
ship around you know I've seen other I
know this isn't joss whedon show but he
definitely has his fingerprints on it he
has his family volume also who actually
are really good writers do I just
watched gods of the arena again you know
Marcus yeah sure you know Marissa and in
in a judge yeah yeah hmm both wrote on
that in a Brad Fletcher who was also uh
Spartacus right yeah there's some very
good writers write and they know I don't
know if it's the limitations cuz God's
arena if any of you guys have seen it
the whole Spartacus thing you know
there's blood sex violence yeah you know
bad word yeah you know there's all these
things you can do right that you're not
limited by the only thing they're really
limited buying that show is kind of
budget right and I know some people will
say like ABC's more family-oriented but
like scandal can get kind of rough
there's some rough stuff in scale and I
get that it's Marvel but they can see
they're trying to appeal to that pg-13
grounds which you can do see the well
that mean and not even pg-13 lower than
pg-13 right because Joss Whedon shows
always a nose doesn't just mean show but
they always had that balance of comedy
and drama a lot of them like Firefly is
the perfect example of how they can you
can go dark we can also be funny and I
hope that they can find a way to do that
somehow and also his shows have Dettori
ously been slow you know remember not
caring about dollhouse until the end of
season one and like you know I've said
this before all the other ones took a
while except for firefly right and this
may be another case of that however this
property is a different story like those
other things were brand new things they
don't expect anything
they were kind of not big budgeted not
ever the eyes weren't on it right this
is a different story yeah you can't play
that uh let's get a whole season under
eye for we start moving right type of
thing yeah and if its exact center say
no we want this episodic thing it's like
well then they're the ones causing the
problem right so I mean it's good to see
you I mean maybe the second half they
can turn on maybe they can I mean we'll
we'll see back we'll see when we come
back in January yeah I mean this is like
one of those bit season finales that has
this cliffhanger that no one cares about
now no one's dying to be like I mean
even the show that you and me have
criticized walking dead at least they
went out with the mid-season finale that
like got me interested like oh man I
want to see right Walking Dead finale
was good we haven't really hard on that
show but yeah that midseason family left
me wanting more so I thought agent
shield could have done right maybe not
as big a turnaround but something yeah
they haven't done it uh I don't know i
mean i'm sure some of you guys are still
enjoying the show and you probably like
oh my god Dennis and David those
bastards but I just gotta you know tell
you the truth it doesn't mean that you
can't like the show oh yeah I just I
just to me is just a disappointment yeah
yeah and we'll see maybe second half
maybe maybe maybe I don't know i'm still
gonna write out there people keep asking
me are you gonna write it out right I'm
like yes I will write out all right the
entire season yeah I don't know we'll be
doing reviews for the time you got some
good shows coming up second half of the
year so let's say alright guys so you
can let us know what you thought you can
put your comfortable on the website the
CARICOM on our youtube channel think
here I'll pro make sure to subscribe to
that post come chat with us on Twitter
talk to dennis michael or myself tell us
about why you love or you hate this show
let's see it kicked off the air will see
gonna find us on at think hero i'm at
griffin de and we have some facebook
page that's a think hero fans and make
sure you like that page and you also
tweet and share our videos on a social
network alright thanks
you